the fallout from Prince Andrew's
controversial TV interview about his
friendship with convicted sex offender
Jeffrey Epstein is intensifying
yesterday the Prince made the stunning
announcement he is stepping back from
his royal duties and this morning we're
seeing the first images of the prince in
public since his decision to step aside
he was seen driving away from his
Windsor home MTS ty Abbas outside
Buckingham Palace in London MTS how much
pressure is the Prince facing from the
US well the lawyers representing the
victims of Jeffrey Epstein say they want
Prince Andrew to cooperate with US
investigators keeping the spotlight on
the Prince even as he tries to step away
from it this whole business is totally
extraordinary for remember the royal
family you don't expect a member of the
royal family to be to be caught up in in
in the life of some seedy pedophile I
mean you just don't a scandal so
extraordinary Prince Andrews had to make
the unprecedented announcement that his
mother the Queen has given him
permission to step back from public
duties for the foreseeable future the
statement follows days of outrage after
this interview he gave about his
relationship with American financier and
convicted sex offender Jeffrey Epstein's
if he could not spend time around him
and not know I live in a in an
institution at Buckingham Palace which
has members of staff walking around all
the time and I don't wish to appear
grand but there were a lot of people who
were walking around Geoffrey Epstein's
house as far as I was aware they were
staff several charities companies and
organizations the Prince supports have
said they're either reviewing or looking
to sever ties with him now that he's
pulling back from public life it's
raising questions about how he'll fund
his royal lifestyle I think he won't
have to leave his royal residence this
is the Queen's son we're talking about
but I think his allowance will probably
go once once you know he's off it's
office will move out at Buckingham
Palace questions continue to swirl
around Prince Andrew's relationship with
Virginia Roberts
- Frey seen here photographed with him
when she was just 17 years old Roberts -
phrase says she was forced to have sex
with the prince at least three times all
at properties owned by Epstein who died
earlier this year in prison and Prince
Andrew statement last night he said he'd
cooperate with law enforcement officials
it fast I mean I think he will have to
be interviewed by the FBI eventually and
because he's not going to be able to lay
it to rest until you know everybody
knows the truth CBS News has learned
that Prince Andrew will no longer
receive around $300,000 a year in public
funds however he will get an allowance
from the Queen from her private funds
and will be expected to attend royal
events including her official birthday
party Tony
MTS taya force in london MTS thank you
very much